they do the gayest State Attorney
Richard Busch is with us now via Skype
from Los Angeles now to discuss the case
Richard how exactly did this fight begin
the fight began and this is a
misconception and in fact the jury
wasn't allowed to hear this but the
fight began because Pharrell Williams
and Robin Thicke actually sued the gay
family for having the temerity to
question whether blurred lines copy got
to give it up so they started this fight
of course we finished it but they
started it if they hadn't started the
fight would you have come in we believed
that it was a copy we were trying to
work things out I think they got advice
that I don't think was very good advice
that if they filed the lawsuit the gay
family would not have the wherewithal or
the ability to fight the financial
resources to fight but they made a bad
bet Richard have I got this straight
that the jury had to come to its
decision on the book by by reading sheet
music couldn't actually hear the
entirety of the songs in question yes
and no so on the one hand throughout
Williams and his legal team tried this
case in the press by saying they did not
copy got to give it up and was just the
copying of a genre or an error and it
was not a copy of God to get it up but
they fought tooth and nail to prevent
the jury from hearing the actual song
and the court made a ruling it's a
rather complicated decision I'll try and
boil it down as as well as I can because
this song got to give it up was created
before 1978 you could not file the
recording as the positive copy you had a
file written note
and the court held that our claim was
limited to those elements that you could
that you could find in the notation that
was filed at the Copyright Office so
there were certain elements that we
could not move forward on and know and
certain that we could and what the court
held was that to play the full recording
would allow the jury to be exposed to
what the court found were non
protectable elements so what we had to
do was prepare very focused audio clips
of the protected elements and compare
those against the same elements and
blurred lines Richard what did this mean
for the broader music industry
specifically hip-hop which relies pretty
heavily on splicing music from decades
ago well I don't think it has any real
effect because they have to get a
license if they're copying they have to
get a license they always have had to
get a license and this is just the
copying of of a song that base should
have license they didn't its copyright
infringement it's no different than any
other copying or any other copyright
infringement claim despite the claim
that this is a copy of a genre or the
copy of an error it's not it's the
copying of a song and they should have
got a license just like everyone else
gets a license when they want to sample
or use composition Richard you've got a
7.4 million dollar judgment what would
you have charged what would your clients
have charged for a license before the
fact well we put on evidence
Nancy Stern who works for Quincy Jones
music and has her own company she does
this all day long every day and it's
clear thousands of uses just like this
and she testified that before the song
was released blurred lines a license
would have been about a 50% share of
blurred lines and that's what the jury
found okay I feel pretty close yeah
pretty close could this have been
avoided I mean when Tom Petty and his
team came a-knockin at Sam Smith's store
Sam basically said sorry and turned over
the money immediately and it didn't
really hit the press and that think of a
way I mean now we know some of Robin
Thicke's very dirty laundry yes they
could have gone a different way they
decided to file this lawsuit like I said
we approached them and how do they
Spahn they failed the lawsuit and I bet
they're wishing they hadn't
Richard what do you do now what do I do
now well what more precisely what what
is Marvin Gaye's estate do now what we
do now is we file a request for an
injunction prohibiting the sale and
further distribution of blurred lines
and the reason why is that the damages
are only for past infringement in order
for us to be able to share in the
proceeds going forward we ask the court
to enjoin the further sale and
distributions do you anticipate that
Robin Thicke and Pharrell at the very
least not to mention the record company
will on the basis of this judgment
entered into negotiations to prevent
that injunction have you heard anything
to that effect from their side
that's what generally happens is the
person bringing the claim gets an
injunction and the parties speak about
and negotiate how proceeds will be
divided going for that's the whole point
of the injunction